revista de prensa en nuestro programa
directo América de Francia 24 y Marta
Moya está con nosotros en el estudio
para hablar de las portadas
internacionales Marta buena mañana de
miércoles y vamos a empezar hoy nuestra
sección de revista de prensa en Polonia
porque tras la caída de un misil en una
ciudad fronteriza con Ucrania pues la
prensa internacional ha recogido toda
las portadas todas las reacciones que ha
generado Esta caída de un misil lo que
decía una parte lo que decía la otra lo
que dijo Estados Unidos lo que
finalmente dijo Polonia y vamos a
empezar con la República precisamente de
Polonia Buenos días Raúl pues vamos a
empezar con el chespospólita de Polonia
que titulaba antes de que se
pronunciaran las autoridades polacas
sobre este misil que habría impactado en
esta ciudad fronteriza con Ucrania decía
según la agencia de noticias
un misil lanzado por Ucrania y esto es
importante el matiz sobre Polonia la
explosión en pez bodobo dejó dos muertos
es una ciudad que se sitúa a 72
kilómetros de El bif que es esta ciudad
que fue ayer bombardeada también con
misiles por las tropas rusas y citando
ya fuentes de la inteligencia
estadounidense avanzaba antes de que se
pronunciaran las autoridades por lacas
que ese misil habría sido un ataque
Bueno una defensa de Ucrania a un ataque
ruso con misiles vamos a ver qué dice
Entonces el país de España Marta el país
también recogía las palabras de Joe
biden que decía que consideraba
improbable que el misil que impactó en
Polonia fuera disparado por Rusia además
recogió una foto curiosa de los líderes
ayer en Bali en el g20 que se filtró por
el Palacio de la moncloa donde están
Pedro Sánchez olafchols macron Richie
son Aquí vaiden tratando este tema que
generó bastante controversia y bastante
urgencia No porque se tuvieron que
reunir los líderes después de que
filtrar a esta noticia de que había
impactado el misil en territorio polaco
y por tanto en territorio del auto no
baiden Ya decía que habría que esperar a
las investigaciones polacas pero que se
descartaba priori que hubiera sido un
misil motivado y deliberado por Rusia
allí será
bueno aunque las autoridades polacas ya
han descartado la aplicación del
artículo 4 del tratado de Washington de
la otan hace un análisis y haciendo un
poco de explainer de que van el artículo
4 y el 5 de este tratado de Washington
no y dice que la guerra entre Rusia y
Ucrania pone a prueba la defensa
conjunta no el artículo 4 solo sea
implementado siete veces desde la
creación de la otan y es un artículo que
se puede
implementar cuando un país de la alianza
se ve amenazado Entonces se llama
consultas y con el máximo
órgano de la alianza atlántica mal
consejo Atlántico se da una prioridad a
esta cuestión no se ha invocado como
decíamos siete veces la última fue en
marzo por 8 países de la alianza que
tienen frontera con Rusia y este
artículo 4 También sirve de preámbulo
del artículo 5 no que es el artículo de
la defensa colectiva nos atacan a uno
defendemos todos al final parece que no
se va a tener que aplicar Pero siempre
es interesante saber un poco Cómo van es
claro Afortunadamente no por el bien
pues el buen curso de lo que puede ser
no una escalada de conflicto pues al
parecer por ahora todo se puede calmar
Qué dice de guardia en Marta el de
guardia nace un análisis que titula es
poco probable que la explosión en
Polonia provoque una escalada pero los
riesgos de un enfrentamiento entre la
otan y Rusia son reales cita pues por
ejemplo el curso en el curso de la
Guerra Fría que Estados Unidos y
entonces la unión soviética se pasaron
toda la Guerra Fría sin atentar el uno
contra el otro porque eran los dos
conscientes de los riesgos que tenía no
empezar una guerra por un error de
cálculo Aunque la Rusia de Putin es una
potencia nuclear más imprevisible que la
unión soviética no cabe esperar o no
cabría esperar sobre todo ya después de
las del pronunciamiento de las
autoridades polacas y acabe todavía
menos esperarlo que esto impulsará una
una escalada de la guerra pero sí las
bueno la solución que puede valorar la
otan sobre todo con estas nuevas
amenazas y estas estos misiles que han
lanzado sobre Ucrania en las últimas
horas puede bueno enviar más armamento a
Rusia a Ucrania perdón y además se
valora a través esta restablecimiento de
la zona de exclusión aérea en el oeste
de Ucrania cambiamos ahora de tema Marta
Porque tras el enuncianoche del ex
presidente estadounidense Donald Trump
que dijo que se iba a presentar
nuevamente como candidato a la
presidencia de 2024 pues se espera que
el partido republicano su partido
vale está este deseo no el presidente
del ex presidente Donald Trump de volver
a lanzarse a la presidencia 2024 como lo
reseñaron los medios estadounidenses
Raúl diversidad aquí de artículos y de
editoriales empezamos con el Washington
post que dice Trump quien como
presidente fomentó una insurrección dijo
que se presenta que se presentará como
candidato ayer lo anunció en su Resort
en mara lago y además en un momento un
poco controvertido no porque los
candidatos que obtuvieron el apoyo sin
fisuras de Donald Trump en las
elecciones de medio término No tuvieron
buenos resultados National review él
hacia la review hace una editorial muy
categórico que titula no dice
parafraseando a voltear después de
asistir a una una vez es un
experimento y dos veces sería perverso
New York Times también en una editorial
dice Estados Unidos merece algo mejor
que Donald Trump dice que él como sus
fieles no pueden presentarse a las
elecciones como
sócratas
dice que por encima de la ley Trump no
podrá
evitar esas investigaciones judiciales
en su contra Aunque presente su
candidatura a la presidencia muy
rápidamente con que cerramos Marta
cerramos con un artículo del curioso
internacional que dice Vladimir Putin
otorga el título de madre heroína a la
esposa de rachmann que es el líder de la
República de chechenia Vladimir Putin ha
revivido esta antigua tradición
soviética por la que se condecora a las
madres de familias numerosas eso es un
premio por los grandes servicios
prestados en el marco del
fortalecimiento de la familia y de la
educación de los hijos es un honor más
alto a las mujeres que tienen hasta 10
hijos y se otorga cuando el último hijo
Cumple un año el premio un millón de
rulos bueno Marta como siempre
Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información mañana más revista de
princesas